SPEAKER 1: I'd like to introduce
our first speaker, Reverend
Floyd Thompkins, who is
the Director of the Center
for Innovation in the Ministry
of San Francisco's Theological
Seminary.
Floyd has also served
as a dean and chaplain
at two world-class institutions,
Stanford and Princeton.
He developed unique,
highly-effective programs
to empower underserved
teenage youth and young adults
in urban and rural areas, in
East Palo Alto and rural south
Georgia.
He led Antioch Baptist
Church, the oldest African
American church in San
Jose, and was the education
and administration pastor
of Covenant Christian
Church in Douglas, Georgia.
And then to his
right, your left,
Reverend Annanda Barclay is a
former theological education
ministry fellow at Austin
Theological Seminary,
where she received her
Master of Divinity degree.
After graduating seminary,
Annanda spent a year
as a student chaplain at
the University of Illinois
at Chicago's Medical Center.
Her services to the
church and denomination
include being co-moderator of
the National Board of Directors
for More Light Presbyterians,
and an occasional blogger
for "Believe Out Loud."
She has since moved
here to the Bay Area
to serve on staff with
First Presbyterian.
In addition to her
work with the church,
she serves and works
with various groups
to strategically advocate the
intersectional justice, love,
and kindness.
Annanda has a deep reverence
for God's grace made manifest
in her, and how
we love each other
and honor ourselves
in God's creations.
And then lastly, Dr.
Reverend Janie Spahr.
She is a lesbian, feminist,
Presbyterian minister
committed to justice issues
for the lesbian, gay, bisexual,
transgender community, pursuing
connections for wholeness
with each other in these
oppressed communities
claiming their freedom.
Janie began her
out liberation work
with her lesbian, gay,
bisexual, and transgender people
back in the 1980s,
when she was a minister
of pastoral care in the Castro
area here in San Francisco.
Since then, Janie has become
one of the most recognized
scholars in this field.
And she is now serving
as the Director
for San Francisco's Theological
School's Reconciliation
Project.
Without further ado, I
will hand the mic over
and let you all get started.
FLOYD THOMPKINS: Hi everyone.
Thank you for
letting me be here.
And it is refreshing that Google
thinks there are questions that
it cannot answer.
That is-- that humility
will go a long way.
I'm Director of the Center
for Innovation and Ministry,
and just want to introduce
one other person,
just in the audience, that
you can talk to afterwards.
And that is Bear Ride, who
is the sister of Sally Ride,
and also is the person
who is the convener
of the Reconciliation Project.
And to her right, is
her partner Susan Craig,
which is one of the--
wonderful person, we go
back 20 years at Princeton.
And she is one of my favorite
people on the planet.
So we're grateful
for them to be here.
I just wanted to
say, I am a person
who is a person of faith, an
ordained Baptist minister,
so I am not Presbyterian.
And also, come from an
evangelical tradition.
I continue to preach
revivals and call people
to the stage for salvation,
and call people to the stage
for having religious
experiences.
And I am also very much
aware and affirming
of the LGBTQ community.
And the question
is, how does one
do it when you take
scripture, as I
do, very, very, very seriously?
Well, first thing is,
to remind ourselves
that it is the word of
God, not the scriptures.
In fact, in the
30,000 scriptures
that are in the
bible, it does not
claim itself to be inerrant.
It claims itself to
be always good for--
profitable for reproof,
profitable for instruction,
profitable for changing.
It's important, but
it also understands
that the spirit of the living
God and the experience of Jesus
is what, in fact, is the
important part of scripture,
and important part
of interpretation.
Because remember,
unless someone was there
when scripture was written,
all of it is interpretation.
So when someone says
to me, well, this
is what the bible says, and
I know it, and this is it,
then there's one or two options.
They're either
actually just unaware
of their own social
location, or it could be
that they're manipulating me.
Or it could be, literally,
that somehow they
want to take their stance
and their understanding
of the bible, their
understanding of faith,
and lay it on me.
Because I'm an
evangelical, I can say,
you know what, you have
your relationship with God.
And I respect that, and
let us reason together.
But at the same time, let us
also come together, and look
and see what the scriptures
say in the context
of the witness of
Christ, and the context
of the witness of God.
Because one always has
to ask, what is going on,
and how is it a religiously
OK thing to exclude someone?
I also come from the--
Steven Biko of South Africa says
that diversity is not something
that is accidental to God.
It is the intentionality
of God to make it diverse,
so that in the diversity
we may discover,
not just our own path,
but the path of God.
So in other words,
if God is not simply
trying to affirm ourselves,
but God is actually
trying to expand ourselves.
And finally, I wanted to
say one of the things I say
around an altar all the time.
It is not interesting that
people believe in God.
Because look, if
the sunrise doesn't
make you believe in God,
then I don't know what will.
What is interesting
is, Jesus comes to say,
no, it is not that
I am so great.
But I am come to tell you
that I believe in you--
that there is in your humanity
something so powerful,
so amazing, that I have
created an image of God.
That when you
accept that and live
that in a collaborative
experience,
you come to know me
in a different way.
Because that is the incarnation.
Other than that, all we have is
another religious expression.
The incarnation, which is Jesus,
makes it mean that the human
experience-- the
diversity itself--
has to be something
that is not accidental,
or something that is
managed, or that is something
that we have to live through--
but actually is the gift of
God to the people of God.
And it is in that gift
that we celebrate today,
and we hear these stories.
It's in that gift that
we allow ourselves
to have all kinds of diversity.
And the same time to say,
truth is in that diversity.
And finally, that truth is
not relative, it is eternal.
But what is relative, is our
understanding, and our growing
to what God is saying.
For instance, in
the Catholic Church,
that's what Vatican
II was all about.
And as we move in prayer--
because other than it,
why pray?
If the only thing you
want to do is say--
if prayer is only the
recitation of saying,
God give me stuff,
then that's not
what I experience as prayer.
Prayer is also,
God show me stuff,
and God, show me how to expand.
When we say in the psalms,
God, enlarge yourself,
God can't get any bigger.
So it's not about God being--
it is meaning a
large vision of God.
And enlarging our vision of
God is how God becomes larger.
So today, I know there are
folks who have differences.
But we come in this place to
say, Lord, enlarge yourself,
which is to enlarge
our vision, so that we
may see you as you
want us to see you,
not as is comfortable to see.
With that, I'm through.
Go ahead.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: So when
it comes to scripture,
I go from the two greatest--
the two commandments Christ
taught us, to love God
with all your heart, soul,
and mind, body, and also to
love your neighbor as yourself.
Those are the two
fundamental scriptures.
So when we're talking about
loving somebody and Christ,
who we all understand to be
fully human and fully divine,
and yet you are made
in the image of God,
then if Christ is the Son of
God and you are children of God,
does that not make us all
fully human and fully divine?
And if we're to go there
and talk about our faith,
and how we enact
our faith, how we're
disciples within our faith--
what do we mean
when we say faith?
And what do we mean when
we're talking about loving
our neighbor as ourselves?
So if we look at
faith, in many ways
faith is not just
faith in God out there,
this God that's in the
heavens and the universes
upon universes.
Faith is also in
the divinity that
is in each and every one of us.
Faith is in the living God that
exists within your neighbor
and yourself.
And so when we talk
about specific subject
of LGBTQ inclusion in the
church, what we're talking
about is, are you
willing to acknowledge
the divinity, the image
of God in your neighbor?
And if you take
away that divinity--
you're not taking it away.
You don't have the
power to take it away.
But if you try to
mute it, or deny it,
are you not also denying
the divinity in yourself?
You are funneling, excluding
God, instead of expanding.
Another theological
approach to that
would be Octavia
Butler, a famous African
American female--
I believe she was queer--
sci-fi novelist.
And her theology
is, God is change,
because change is inevitable.
That is one thing I would
assume Google knows very well.
AI is a big deal.
Change constantly, there is no
sameness-- so in the same way,
our expansion and understanding
of God must change as we grow
and spiritually mature.
A sign of spiritual stagnancy
is sticking our heels in.
And if we look at Christ's
ministry in all four gospels,
Christ is constantly being
changed by those he encounters.
He does not stay the
same in his ministry.
His divinity is the
same, so is yours.
His humanity is the
But he's willing to be
changed and transformed,
and in turn his ministry grows.
And we know him
2000-years-plus, to this day.
So that's more of
the approach that I
take with this as an
overall expansion,
and we'll funnel it
down with questions.
But I would encourage you all
to look at your own divinity,
and to see the divinity of
others, because it's important.
And if you miss it, you miss God
in the everyday interactions.
And it becomes easy
to other somebody.
It becomes easy to
discard somebody.
It becomes easy to deny
another their humanity, which
is their inherent right for the
simple fact that they exist.
JANE SPAHR: Whoa.
Hi.
I want to look at this
from another angle
too, from personal angle.
Because I'm 75 years
old, I'd live a long time
to also see tremendous change.
And with that, the change of
course happened inside of me
also.
In which, learning
that I was lesbian,
I always said that the
reason why I am lesbian
is because of God.
And people don't
understand that many times.
And this is what I went from.
I went from, oh, my god,
because I was culturated,
I was in a church.
I was told all these
horrible things
about what people
call gay people.
And so that's inside of me--
that was inside of me.
So I went from oh, my
god, to thank you, God.
And I did that because
of some amazing people,
like my former
husband Jimmy, who
loved me into loving myself.
It was two wonderful
children who
are now 50 and 48, who
loved their mother and said,
Mommy, don't worry
that you are lesbian,
it's God made you that way.
This is who you are.
So I've had tremendous
support in learning
what it is to be in love
with what God made me.
For instance, when I realize
and my deepest feelings were
for my friends and yet we had--
I have a twin sister, so
we had lots of boyfriends,
we had lots of people
around us and so on.
But the most
important thing was I
knew, even in
marrying Jimmy Spahr,
that the deepest place
inside of me was not met.
And I call it that
God place deep inside.
And then when I realized--
when I went from oh, my god,
to thank you, God, it was
like, wow, this is fabulous.
I can be myself.
I can really be who I am.
And with that then, these are
the other questions that came.
Well, if people
are off about this,
and they only see us as
mythology or stereotypes,
then who else is
being stereotyped?
Who else is being told--
you know, how am I being duped?
Or how am I complicit
with a culture that
stereotypes and
labels and says, this
is what it is to
be this or that?
And with that, not only
did God expand within me,
but I expanded.
And it was this
tremendous meeting
of who God is within us, and
around us, and beside us.
So then when I
came out, thinking
the church would surely
love us, because then we
can be who we are,
the church says, no.
I'm like, what?
We're finally who we
are, we can finally--
we can give our gifts fully,
we don't have to be afraid.
We don't have to hide.
This is an amazing
thing that happens,
and then they don't want us.
So I think the church
had to learn from us,
it's to meet us--
it's to meet who we are
as LGBTQ Christians.
It's to see who we are.
It's to hear our life,
it's to hear our faith.
This is how we change.
I mean, I've been
in so many debates
around scripture,
and so on like that.
But when you meet
us, and you see us,
and you meet someone like
Annanda, you feel this--
you begin to hear that we
too are people of faith.
We too are people that have
the same struggles, that
have the same things that we're
looking for, the same dreams.
So it's in that way I find
that scriptural debate has
been something that
I find is heady,
and it moves away from the
personhood of who Christ
is within us.
And with that, that then breaks
us away from one another.
So throughout the
country as I traveled,
it was things like this
that people would say.
They would say, well, God,
you really can preach,
as though we wouldn't
preach from the text.
And meeting people
for the first time--
people hearing gay
is good, and you
are who you are because of God.
Can you imagine?
We went into one
church in Alabama.
And you knew every LGBTQ
person in the place,
because they laid their
heads down and wept,
because no one had
ever said to them,
this is such a good thing,
this is such a God thing,
of who you are.
It is in that kind of
travel as we moved around,
as we moved in churches
where people were
afraid to say who they were.
And so they'd say
things like this--
well, thanks, Janie,
for coming, but there's
no other gay people here.
And there was always someone who
stood in the church and said,
but I'm here, I'm here.
And they go, Sally?
Our Sally, our one who's our
deacon, our most faithful
person?
It happened in every faith
community that we went to.
It happened in Iowa
with grandmothers
who said, we've been
waiting for you to come,
because I have a wonderful
lesbian granddaughter,
and I've wanted to say it
out loud to my whole church.
It's meeting people, it's
hearing their stories,
it's feeling who they are.
It isn't-- I would say, who
do people think Jesus was?
He was a radical.
He was a radical rebel.
He took on people who said
that women were not equal.
He changed the theme of that.
He talked about Samaritans
that are different.
And he said, there they
are in the realm of God.
They're part of God.
Everything that he did
challenged the status quo
of the time.
That's what he did.
He was a radical rabbi.
And so I always thought,
well, isn't that
what we're supposed to be doing?
Aren't we supposed
to be challenging
these systems of oppression
that keep us from one another?
So that's, I think, our job--
is to live into
that, and challenge
everything in which they say,
these people are that way--
no.
And I'll tell you
one more story.
A person called me on
the phone and they said,
are you Janie Spahr?
And I said, yes.
He said, do you know that
there is a complaint being made
against you in Philadelphia?
I said no, no I didn't.
He said, you mean nobody
called you to tell you this?
I said no, nobody called me.
He said, well, then, I
want to know who you are.
I want to hear your faith.
I want to hear how you
love, who you love.
I want to know who you are.
And we had this
amazing conversation.
And he went back to that
governing body and he said,
how many of you
know Janie Spahr?
How many of you called her
and asked her about her faith?
How many of you know who she is?
Well, I do.
I called her, and I know
her, and I talked to her.
And I'm voting for her, and
god, I'd wish you'd do the same.
It's that kind of change
that has to happen.
And then when you watch people
that are so hurt by the church,
or by community--
the church has been the greatest
perpetrator of injustice
against LGBTQ people.
So those of us that are
still in the church, you see,
are trying to spread this good
news of God's love for all.
This is what we're trying to
do, because the church has been
so unjust in labeling
and framing us
as less than, as second class.
So we're here.
We're here, we're queer, and we
love that God made us this way.
And this is why we've
come here, to say, yay.
You know, this is
the realm of God
that is so diverse
and so wonderful,
so let's not bring it back
into this tight script.
God is so magnificent,
and that's why we're here.
Thanks for having us.
FLOYD THOMPKINS: Wanted
to own one other thing,
because as we're
sitting here, also,
the other thing that happens
in scripture, I think--
you know, there's also a
social location, right?
I'm a black male and
you're like, well,
you're black, [INAUDIBLE]
straight, why is this an issue?
Because remember,
African Americans,
when you say, we're scripture
and everything else,
there's that scripture called
slaves, obey your master.
Um, which kind of is
the deal for us, right?
[LAUGHS] if everything
in this bible is true,
and that scripture is
true, then not only
is it a text of
terror, but the church
becomes a terroristic
organization to us, right?
And that's not who we've
experienced it, though.
Because actually, the church
became the place of liberation
in slavery.
Because it begins-- it's a
place of affirming humanity.
And so then, by definition,
we have to work in scripture.
Then, you look at the Greek,
then you look at the Hebrew.
Then, you look and say,
what is the heart of God?
So I just wanted
to say that this
is-- because one of
the pre-questions
is like, well, you're changing
because times are changing.
No, we're changing-- at
least I'm not, quite frankly.
By being a person that
believe in Jesus Christ
and open the bible and
seeing that scripture,
I obviously--
that's the beginning
of the point of change.
Because that scripture
calls me in to look to say,
is that true, and is that
representative of God?
And if that's what God
is saying about us, then
therefore this can't be true.
But then, you look at the
context of that scripture.
You look at the words
of that scripture,
and then you see
something new, and then
you start seeing
scripture that way.
So I just wanted to
also own that there
is some connectedness also to
the understanding of scripture,
and I think sometimes that's
what social location is.
I think women have to do
it very naturally also,
if, in point of fact, you accept
some of the scriptures that
says, only men can do this and
that must be what it means.
Then, I think as
a woman Christian,
there's going to be
some issues, saying,
was this the God
I need to serve?
That's not the Jesus
I fell in love with.
So there is a different stake
that I come to scripture with.
Because to love Jesus
and to be a black man,
I am interacting with scripture
from that social location.
So that may be a different
location from a white man.
That may be a different
location from a person of color.
But that location is
what I want to call into.
And also, that blindness--
there is a blindness to say,
I don't see why you just
don't see it like that.
Well, of course you won't,
because it works for you.
But it doesn't work for Jesus.
It didn't work for the--
you know, that's
why people were--
I got to watch my language.
That's why people were
not happy with Jesus.
Because let's face it,
he looked and said,
yo, I hear what you're
saying, it's just not--
and I got you, Paul.
At least, I got you, Saul, but
you've got to become a Paul.
And that means you're actually
going to have to evolve.
Saul to Paul is about evolving.
And so that's the Jesus
that calls us into this.
It's not easy, it's not
necessarily comfortable,
but it is absolutely faithful.
It is what scripture does.
And then to ask me
not to do it, is
to then tell me that I'm not
your brother, your sister--
I should be a slave
obeying my master.
And that is something--
you all, I don't know you, but
I ain't going to do that, OK?
And also, I think that's what
gay and lesbian people are
like.
OK, you know what,
that's really nice,
and I hear what you're saying,
but no, because I will not
be destroyed in that way.
So anyway, I just
wanted to throw
that in about interconnectivity
and where we come from.
It's not just the
political times,
it is the fundamental
understanding.
And like I said
to Nick, we're not
interested in having a
political conversation--
absolutely boring.
But we're interested in having
a spiritual conversation, where
we all are.
And therefore, there's
grounds for disagreement.
But yet, brotherhood
and sisterhood,
that then brings us together
as we're moving forward.
ANNANDA BARCLAY:
Siblinghood, too.
FLOYD THOMPKINS: Siblinghood?
ANNANDA BARCLAY: Siblinghood.
JANE SPAHR: Yes.
Evolving.
FLOYD THOMPKINS:
Evolving siblinghood.
JANE SPAHR: And
we've all evolved.
I mean, we have evolved to come
to acceptance of ourselves,
and to who we are.
Because so much around us
said, no, you can't be.
And we said, yes, we can.
Yes we can, because of God.
That makes people cranky, you
know, but it's true, it's true.
Isn't it?
ANNANDA BARCLAY: It is.
So I think we take questions
now, or where are we at?
SPEAKER 1: It seems
like the debate
in church about
homosexuality comes
down to how I read the bible.
In your experience,
have Christians
changed how they read scripture
specifically in response
to this issue of what you
just-- you mentioned that psalm,
but I don't know if
anybody wants to elaborate.
JANE SPAHR: Well,
again, I think so much--
again, we've done so much
on this and the bible.
And when you do this, you
think surely people see this,
and hear this, it's very clear.
It's not.
And so what we have found in
traveling the country and so
on--
what I've found, it's when they
meet us and hear our faith,
and see who we are.
And to see that we
too are like you.
And it's so wonderful
to see people open,
because otherwise
people are very closed,
although they have
this stereotype of who
they think we are.
And then to see us, and that
we too are people of faith,
and we too love God and so.
That's where I've seen
most change happen,
is finally to meet
us face to face.
Sometimes scripturally, but it
usually doesn't work that way.
I haven't seen it.
FLOYD THOMPKINS: And
I think you're talking
with the notion of hermeneutic.
Which is, again, starting
off saying we all start
from an interpretive reality.
We have a relationship at the
center with the King Papers
Project at Stanford.
And so you know, every
word King's ever written
is down there.
And what is interesting,
there's a reoccurring theme
that he has, which
is-- you know,
this guy went on and got a
PhD at Boston University,
higher criticism,
all of those things.
Although he didn't-- anyway--
but he would say, I
learned everything I
need to learn in Sunday school.
He keeps saying that
over and over again.
Not that all of the other
criticism didn't help him.
But ultimately, it was
the experience with God,
interaction with those
simple stories of who Jesus
was presented to me, that
became the framework of all
of the social justice
and understanding
in the framework of my
theology and academic work.
Because what brought
him to Boston
was Boston personalism,
which is the idea
that you move out of a
personal experience with God.
And that always become
the hermeneutics
of that, which allows you to
take the tools that you have,
and it will always be
an expression of that.
And then sometimes those
tools will make that change,
but it's that interaction
that he talks about.
And there's a very
famous thing in some
of the things that was written,
when everyone was talking
about his speech on war.
And all of his
advisers were looking
at every political possibility,
and why he shouldn't
stand up and whatever.
They looked at him
and he said, oh, yeah,
I'm going to do the speech.
It's like, why?
Because it's wrong-- Vietnam War
is wrong, and I believe that.
And you can give
me all the reasons,
but I know it's wrong from what
I knew from what they taught me
in Sunday school.
And so at some point, yeah,
biblical interpretation changes
as you get more tools.
But it's also got to
be allowed to change.
So it's funny that higher
criticism has not hurt faith.
It only expands it, in that way.
So yeah, that's some
changes that have happened.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: I
think scripturally, too,
if we're wanting to look
at the biblical text,
both in the Hebrew
bible and the Greek.
We look at Christ's
teachings, he in turn
tells-- first off, we never
see Christ in a synagogue.
We have in one or
two gospels, we
hear Christ as a child talking
to folks within the temple.
And outside he turns
the tables over,
but in general, Christ
is rarely actually
in designated religious spaces.
So I think as Christians we
create this myth that Christ
was already in the "church" as a
Jewish rabbi, which isn't true.
And then we also create
this myth that Christ
was strict to scripture,
which is actually
what got him in trouble, was his
reinterpretation of the law--
which is a radical
diversion from how
it was previously interpreted.
And so the third
approach I'd take to that
is, when we're talking
about evolving,
because that's been a
theme for our panel,
would not we as Christians
2,000 years later
also evolve in our understanding
and depth of the interpretation
of scripture?
And is that not also, not
just mimicking, but learning
from Christ's own life,
and Christ's own witness
to ministry?
And I think to not do
that is a spiritual crime.
I think that that
actually is what
robs ourselves of being able to
live a deeper and fuller life.
Similar to Janie, once
I came out for myself--
it was the first
semester of grad school,
and I finally saw
other LGBTQ Christians
who didn't have as much
fear, who didn't necessarily
hate themselves.
And it was a loving
church environment.
Because I could not reconcile
to be Christian and to be LGBTQ.
I didn't think it was possible.
And what I realized was, similar
to Stokely Carmichael's speech
"Black Power," that
the church's rules--
both the laws written and
culturally, sociologically
embodied--
were not for gay people.
They weren't for LGBT people.
It was to protect those
who feared LGBTQ people,
for whatever reason.
Similarly, for the
laws of segregation--
those aren't for black people.
Black people know
we're fully human,
counted in the Constitution
despite the Three-Fifths rule.
So that wasn't for
black people, that
was for white supremacists,
to put something
on the books as
a discrimination.
And so when we talk about
discriminating against people
within the name of
God, we are falsely
claiming the audacity, truly,
to falsely speak for God.
And then to make an
exclusion that dehumanizes
another person, is a problem.
And it's one that
should be tackled
with love to a certain degree,
but when you have folks who--
many of us know folks who
have killed themselves,
who have hurt themselves,
who have been beat up,
who have been put out on the
street, who cannot get a job,
who cannot find a
roof over their head.
That's a problem.
That's a human problem,
and that is one directly
caused by the church in
the false name of Christ.
And so when we take
a look at scripture,
again, are you loving
your neighbor as yourself?
And do you love yourself enough
to have the courage to love
somebody who is different?
FLOYD THOMPKINS: That's
a preacher, you all.
SPEAKER 1: How would
you advise Christians
to accept the LGBTQ community
that finds themselves violating
principles of exegesis
while trying to frame
a justification of that?
JANE SPAHR: I think
you just answered it.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: Yeah.
Yeah.
FLOYD THOMPKINS: Well,
it's a false premise, that
somehow that if I exegesis--
I mean, it's the same thing
that the Southerners said,
look, that's what
the scripture do
say, slaves, obey your master.
Now, I don't know how I can--
I like you all and
everything, but quite frankly,
if the scripture says that
you just have to be slaves,
I'm sorry.
Because that's what
scripture says, right
And that's exactly what
you're saying, the exegesis.
I mean, and that's probably
offensive to someone that says,
I'm not like that, but that's
exactly what you're saying.
You're saying you
cannot read the bible.
You're telling someone, I
cannot read the bible and love
somebody.
Because I read the bible,
I have to exclude you, not
accept you, not believe you.
I can read the
bible and say, look,
I want a set of
humility that says,
I read the bible this way.
This is what I believe.
But I'm willing to
dialogue with you,
and come to that point of seeing
how we can love each other.
And because I know the
Jesus of the bible,
I know some way I'm
supposed to love you.
Now, I might be stuck in my
exegetical world like this.
And I may have to
keep doing that.
But I'm not going to say by
being stuck in that, it's over.
One of the more important
thing is, it's not over.
This is what causes a
stuck, angry Christian.
Because what happens is you go--
because your soul
is being violated.
There's something
within you that says,
I know there must
be something more,
but instead I'm afraid
to even look at it.
Look at it.
It doesn't mean that I even
understand it totally right
now, but I understand that
the Jesus that I know,
and the witness of
this gospel somehow
doesn't fit what's going on.
Let me keep going on.
And by the way, I think if
you do really good exegesis--
you're Google, so you guys
you can Google this stuff--
you know it's out there.
But keep doing it.
Now, at the same time
if you say, look,
I don't want to do
it, well, that's fine.
But then realize
you're going to see
my image in your
head going, exactly,
that slavery analogy,
which is fine.
I mean, we have a lot of--
I know some folks who basically
say, I can't love you,
because the bible
tells me I can't.
That's fine, if that's
what you want to be.
But if that's not
what you want to be,
keep looking, and find a way
to say, what does God say?
And I don't know how you come
to your own path of doing that,
but that's the problem with--
not the problem with
the question, that's
the challenge of that question.
It's stuck in the fact that
you can't have real exegesis
and then believe this,
and that's just not true.
JANE SPAHR: I think
everything you're
saying here, and justice--
it isn't just what's
going on there,
when you can only
look at it that way.
It isn't just, and Jesus
was all about justice,
and turning things over.
And I want to give
a thing too, where
I have, again, this changing
people's minds and hearts.
When I went to
Oklahoma, I had heard
that there was a
couple that absolutely
believed that LGBTQ
people were going to hell
and had a strict thing of how
they looked at scripture and so
on.
So the person raised his
hand, and I was ready--
because you're ready, you're
talking about your life.
And I said, yes?
And he said, well, you know
how I feel about homosexuality
and so on like that.
And I said, yes.
And he said, well, let me
tell you what happened to me.
He said, our son came home from
Oberlin College two weeks ago,
and said, Mom and
Dad, there's something
I want you to know about me,
and that is that I'm a gay man.
I'm a gay, Christian man.
So he said, so what do you
think we did, Janie Spahr?
And I said, what
did you do, Gary?
And he said, we love our son.
We love our son,
and God would never
ask us to choose to
go against our son.
So this was the
turnaround there.
And then, he said this.
So what you're doing
around the country--
I'll tell you what
I'm going to do.
He said, I'm going
to give you $5,000
every year until you
can find the church
that you want to find.
And that's when they got upset.
They saw the turn, but
then it's about economics,
and that's a whole other thing--
about, oh my god, not
only that, but he's
going to give money
toward this thing.
And that's another thing, but
that's about justice, you see?
And he learned it
about his own kid.
And my friend Sandy said
the same thing-- don't ever
ask me to choose between
the bible and my child,
because I will always
choose for my child.
Because this is God
of love and justice
would never ask me
not to love my child.
And yet we've seen it.
Only what happens to many of
those children that are not
accepted by their family
and so on, many of them,
as you have said, we have
buried, we have been with,
and we have tried to love
them into loving themselves.
But when you have
buried young people
because they have
killed themselves,
when you have [? been ?]
them in such a way,
this is what we say--
it is not enough
that you love me.
It is not enough
Then you must vote for me.
Then you must vote
for my rights.
Then I know you love me.
It's not a love, because
love without justice
is no love at all.
And this is what we're
talking about here.
We're talking about when
people are seen as less
than, from a God who loves
and accepts us for who we are.
And then, to treat people as
though they are nothing, as
though they are second class.
I have done this for
50 years, and watched
this and it's no more--
no more.
We can't keep doing it.
Love and justice--
Jesus talked about
love and justice,
said they have to be together.
That's what we're
talking about here,
and how we read the bible,
and how we look at it.
And those of us here--
a wild feminist, she's got
it right here on the thing.
Feminist, you know what it is
to try and read the scriptures
through the context of feminist
women, as women of color,
as reading through
the context and stuff.
And there it all comes,
and you don't think.
Then I look at some
of these scriptures,
and you don't think that
in the boat when they're
talking about 12 boys
being in the boat,
you don't think that there
are children in that boat,
and women in that boat--
and they're all people of color.
All people of color,
that's who they are.
That's what we
have to talk about.
We have to talk about
these Scriptures.
Where were they?
What was the context,
and what is it now?
What is it now?
And how can we read into
that where we are now?
And what does that say, in
how we live and how we behave?
All around the country,
everywhere I went,
they always wanted to
know how I was a lesbian.
I never asked, how are
you a heterosexual?
I would never ask that.
Do you see what I'm saying?
But not one person
asked me, how do
you spend your money,
what's your economics,
how do you feel about war?
How's Christ in your life?
Not ever once--
it was always, how
does it feel to be a lesbian?
Well, it's all of it together.
I'm a whole person.
It's one of the many,
many parts of me.
And I'm a Christian.
And I follow the
one who challenged
every system that says no,
that says no to the truth.
That's what I've
seen, and that's
why I still do this, because
I don't want to bury one more
child because somebody says
they were bad boys or bad girls.
I will not do it.
So that's why I'm
still doing this work.
So didn't mean to--
SPEAKER 1: It actually leads
into the next question.
You answered some
of this, but if you
want to elaborate on it more.
Someone asked,
how would you like
to see other Christians
respond to and support
LGBTQ Christians, including
LGBTQ Christians coming
from a variety of
theological perspectives?
FLOYD THOMPKINS:
I want to say one
thing about the exegetical
thing as I answer that.
It is commendable that if
you're stuck there about LGBTQ,
you also end up getting
stuck about women.
Because I am a son of a
woman minister, who battled
hard to accept her call.
And the same people who didn't--
because they was stuck
exegetically in the same way.
So you understand, if
you're stuck there,
I just ask you to
continue to fight.
To say, is this God?
And if there is something
in your soul that's saying,
you know, I'm excluding
50% of humanity,
then I'm excluding this.
I'm only left with
only one people, which
is men are the only people that
God works with and speaks to.
And if that's the case, I don't
know anybody in this room--
and I don't know you-- who
probably would say, that's OK.
So that's the exegetical
trap you're in.
I just wanted to follow
that out, and say--
and by the way, there are
whole church denominations
that are fighting
that trap right now,
because they realize that's
what you do when you go there.
In terms of the ally--
I'll talk about being allies.
Part of the ally, is actually to
be the person who speaks truth
honestly.
Who says, honestly,
you know what?
People have to evolve.
I use the word evolve.
Fortunately, I was the first
person to talk, so now we got
evolve in this
thing, or expand God.
But the notion is, is
that it is an evolution,
and that people can.
So first thing I say to allies
is that, OK, it will be OK,
you can grow.
And by growth,
means we don't know
where we're going to end
then, but we can grow.
The second thing is always
to stand with and for those
who are like Jesus--
those who are the most
vulnerable and the most hurt.
Because quite frankly,
that's the gospel.
And so the notion of
not being intimidated
by a very sometimes
mean-spirited and small mindset
that says to you in general if
you believe that, a, you either
must be one of them or you're
not really a Christian.
The way to answer that is
to laugh and keep moving.
And why I say laugh is because
when people feel like that,
you know what?
Let God handle them.
What you need to keep
handling is what you handle,
which is keep loving.
You know what I'm saying?
Absolutely.
Can I take a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm still sort of formulating
my question, so forgive me.
I don't know, it's
not clear or anything.
But thank you for coming here.
And I know it's such
a controversial topic,
and I know that--
sorry, I don't know your name,
you're sitting in the middle.
Actually, all of you were
talking a lot about, like,
loving our neighbor,
loving everyone else.
And I totally, like--
this is what we're called
to do as Christians.
But I also believe that
there's a difference
between loving the image
of God and loving sin.
And of course, I'm saying
that because I believe
that homosexuality is a sin.
And I still haven't
found anywhere
in Scripture that
says otherwise.
So I don't know.
And while I was praying
about this too last week
Revelation 2 came to mind
about the compromising church
and you're not just all--
I have so very messy
thoughts so I don't know.
So like, if you have any
comments or thoughts about that
I would like to hear.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: So the
Christian Orthodox definition
of sin is that
which separates us
from our truest
self, our humanity.
I cannot help that I was
born queer any more than
the mahogany of my skin.
And so when we talk about sin,
sin is a behavior, not a being.
It is a choice that one makes
to depart from your true self.
And because you are made
in the image of God--
because we all are.
Because we all have a divinity
within us-- that turning away
from our true self
is turning away
from our divinity,
our divineness.
And so if we are to limit--
I'll go with your logic.
If we are to limit
the sexuality of God
to heterosexual, although
you have two clearly
queer, non-heterosexual
people in front of you,
then we are still narrowing God.
And neither of us can
be anything but queer,
because that is our
truest human nature.
And it's different from
yours, as it's diverse.
But-- not but.
And, sexuality is not simply
a behavior, which I think
is part of what people think.
Because people sometimes
think, oh, you're LGBT--
oh-- I shouldn't say
T, because T is gender,
it's not sexuality.
So LGBQ-- and say, well, it's
OK if you don't act on it.
As if my sexuality is
only watered down to sex--
the act of sex, in particular.
Whereas folks who are straight
are never necessarily told,
well, your straightness
is OK, and we don't even--
it's not even a question
if you act or not act
on your straightness, because--
do you behave straight?
AUDIENCE: I mean, we all
sin in different ways.
Straight people, if
they commit adultery.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: So I
want to keep you on track.
I'm not talking about adultery.
Is straight a behavior?
AUDIENCE: It is not.
It is an identity, and
so is homosexuality.
But the practice of
homosexuality is a sin.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: So the
practice of homosexuality
is a sin more so than the
practice of heterosexuality,
even though the actions
might be the same?
Although, the parts might
be a little different--
the connecting parts.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: The practice
of heterosexual really
before marriage according
to the bible is a sin.
And so they are equally sin.
ANNANDA BARCLAY:
All right, so I'll
go down this rabbit
hole with you,
and then I'll shut it down.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: OK.
So I'll go down the
rabbit hole of marriage.
Biblical marriage
was never necessarily
between one man and one woman.
If we look at David,
he had a whole harem.
Abraham, he had Hagar and Sarah.
And so if we look at
marriage biblically,
and in particular the act
of sex within marriages,
it is not biblically just
between one man and one woman.
Historically
throughout the bible,
that comes far later, if
it comes really at all.
It's always ambiguous.
So when we talk about biblical
interpretation of families,
that interpretation
is super new,
because biblical families
are all kinds of complex.
And so when we say that
scripture's inerrant,
it goes back to what
Floyd was saying.
If you are going to
lay that lens on it,
then Floyd and I should
still be in shackles.
If we're going to
lay that lens on it,
Janie and I should
not be ordained.
If we're going to lay that lens
on it, all of us women in here
should have our heads covered
in scarves at all times.
And so when we pick
specific scriptures
because we believe that
they are inherently sinful,
well, let's talk
about what is sin.
Some of us should not be eating
shellfish, if that's the case.
And so when we look at the
law and how we interpret it,
I want us to be
mindful of, again,
those first two commandments
that Christ said
are the most important.
Love God with all your heart,
soul, your mind, your body.
And love your
neighbor as yourself.
And so I ask of you to struggle
with seeing somebody who is not
straight just as divine just
as worthy and just as sinless
as you.
AUDIENCE: I am not sinless.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: But that's what
I'm saying, just as sinless--
so no more, no less.
JANE SPAHR: Can I
also say too about
marriage-- because just
exactly what you're saying,
the dynamics of family
and so on in the bible,
they're very different.
It doesn't give us a thing.
Let me just say those of us who
are honored to do marriages--
I do marriages.
I meet with people for a year.
This is what I say.
I want you to have a healthy,
loving mutual relationship.
That is not in the
bible as far as--
it's usually in the bible,
is that women were property.
And we were seen as less
than, and we were only defined
by the men that we loved.
Honest, that's what it is--
talk about sin, talk about
power over relationships.
We're talking about
today of having marriages
that are mutually
loving together,
that honor, that are just.
And this is what I do.
I don't care if you're gay,
straight, whatever you are.
For a year we meet,
and we do all that work
about what it means
to be in love.
And who supports you, and
what community is around you,
so that you're not in isolation.
Is there a faith community
that honors who you are?
So for those of us--
my being lesbian, I
believe, is not a sin.
I believe it's a gift.
And it's all about identity,
it's not about behavior.
Now, how I behave, is am
I loving to my partner, is
it mutual, is it just?
I would ask that of any of
us who dare to be married.
So this sin-- where we get
caught is this behavior.
And as you're saying,
it's all about sex.
And we're saying, we don't
want you to just look at us.
Like, we want you to look
at us as whole people.
But what happens is, gay
people are seen as behavior.
We are not seen as whole
people who were made also
in the image of God.
And so that's where it gets hard
for us to hear that who we are
is sinful.
Because if we act in
ways that are unjust,
if we act in ways
that are not mutual,
if we act in ways that we
treat people as less than,
yes, I'm right with you.
But that's the behavior
we're talking about.
We're not talking
about our very being--
our very being.
AUDIENCE: I struggle a lot
with something you said.
I think you repeated
it a couple times.
When somebody doesn't
tolerate LGBTQ people,
they say, because of God,
or because of bible--
I struggle with that part
of what you said, to say,
that's fine.
FLOYD THOMPKINS: I
didn't say that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
let me rephrase it.
So when people
don't tolerate, they
behave in a way
that's discriminatory
and they justify that, I have
a hard time not acting on it
with, even if it
doesn't belong to me.
And I struggle
sometimes with, like,
letting them be, and realize let
God take care of it, versus me
just yelling at them.
I don't really know
what's the line there.
FLOYD THOMPKINS: If you got
that impression, I apologize.
But if they act--
kind of what Janie--
if they act unjustly,
if they use their power to hurt
people because they're LGBTQ,
then you stand up for anybody.
That's what I say
about being there.
However, to argue with
someone about their beliefs ad
infinitum is just not
worth the time, one.
And two, because I actually
believe in a real God.
And every conservative in
this room will understand.
And I actually believe
in the power of prayer.
It doesn't mean I'm
going to let you be.
It just means whatever
you need, I don't have.
So I'm going to pray
for two things--
either someone that
has it, you meet,
or either God gives
you experiences
that you will open up.
I'm old enough that a
lot of people in my life
have come back in
my life who thought
I was a heretic and
blah, blah, blah,
who now 15 years later
come back to apologize.
And a reason they can apologize
is I stayed in relationship,
and looked at it
and went, you know
what, I'm going to tell
you what I believe.
You got what you
believe, you're not
hurting anybody in my presence,
and I'm going to pray for you.
And that's what it is.
Because the yelling
at them is kind
of almost a self-affirming
thing, which is really nice,
but it actually is not moving
the ball down the road,
and it may be destroying
the relationship.
Because you actually
might have what people--
everybody in this room
understands psychology.
So a lot of times when
people hear stuff,
they're angry with
you the first time,
just because of where
they are developmentally.
But you stay in
relationship with them.
One of the things that
I love about Janie Spahr
is she's going to stay
in relationship with you.
And because she's in
relationship with you,
you know that you can come
back and ask questions and say
like the person in the back
row who asked that question.
I appreciate that she stood
up and asked the question.
She said, it's
formulating in my mind.
And I hear what you're saying.
I totally disagree with you.
You disagree with me.
But I believe that
the God who is moving
is a God that is going to
move us to the right place.
So that's what I meant.
But no, clearly if somebody
is being discriminated
against somebody being yelled
at, somebody being hurt,
clearly you stand up.
It's kind of what I do.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
was asking,
how should we act to
the Nashville Statement,
both within and
out of the church?
So I don't know if someone
can summarize what that is,
just briefly?
FLOYD THOMPKINS: Can
you put up the Center
for Innovation and Ministry?
The Spark Committee
just yesterday
actually put together
a statement in reaction
to that statement.
And as you put it up,
I'm going to throw it
to Annanda and Janie to
talk about that clearly.
SPEAKER 1: Would you
like to read it out?
FLOYD THOMPKINS: OK.
Yeah, I can read it out.
"Jane Adams Spahr
Reconciliation Project
affirms the beautiful,
sacred diversity
of all God's creation,
proclaiming and celebrating
that we are all children of
God, holy loved and cherished
by our Creator.
As a council spiritual
leaders, we whose stated goal
is the creation of healthy,
thriving, authentic communities
of faith, we reject
the Nashville Statement
issued by the Council of
Biblical Manhood and Womanhood
on August 30, 2017.
Further, we reject any other
statements or manifestos
that teach anything other
than the full welcoming
and inclusion of
our queer family
and all our faith communities
and societies, both locally
and internationally.
The Jane Adams Spahr
Reconciliation Project
continues its work in
opening the hearts and minds
of faith communities
towards LGBTQ community,
welcoming fully those who
have been silenced or excluded
as members and leaders.
We are steadfast in this
ministry and outreach.
We stand without
compromise or apology.
We do not cower before
erroneous and hurtful statements
or practices to marginalize
our God-given human family."
And that is our statement
that came from the committee.
And I'm going to let these
two wonderful people continue
on there.
Also, check our Facebook page.
Innovation and Ministry has
a couple other reactions,
and you can react to them also.
Go ahead.
ANNANDA BARCLAY: I like to say,
contrary to popular belief,
sense is not common.
Because if sense was common, we
wouldn't need this statement.
If sense is common,
black people wouldn't
be on pavements bleeding.
If sense was common, Janie
would not have to continue this
ministry-- this particular
part of this ministry,
50 years going--
for LGBTQ inclusion
in the church.
If sense was common, we
would be able to look
at the differences within each
other and accept them as gifts.
Because the truth
of the matter is,
we are all here for a
reason, and we're not
coming back in this form,
in the same way again.
There will never be another
person before you or after you
the way you are--
the gifts that you have,
and the experiences
that you can bring to the
world, and the communities
that you can build.
But in order to
do that, you have
to live fully into
yourself, and you
have to accept and acknowledge
the full humanity of those
around you, in order to build.
It's easy to destroy.
Honestly, it's very easy--
it's easy to break
something apart.
It is hard to work with
somebody and accept who they
are, and build something up.
It is incredibly hard
for humanity to do.
I mean, Nashville,
that's a bunch of mess.
We all know this.
And I'll be honest, part of
my frustration in my voice,
is after a while you get tired.
When people cry out and say
that you are discriminating
against me, after a while
you get tired of crying out.
How many generations of
queer people have to do this?
And so at some point for those
who do not identify or embody
LGBTQ, at some point you
have to ask yourself,
how long can you continue to
discriminate against somebody?
And how long can you be
complacent with that?
And would you not rather
build something up?
I'm not saying you have
to like all LGBTQ people,
but you do have to respect
them beyond tolerance.
I don't want to be tolerated.
I want to be respected.
And I want you to be just as
respected, no more no less
than I. And so for me
with statements like that,
I mean they're so blatant.
Why are we having a discussion?
The discussion isn't for me.
As a queer person, the
answer is quite clear.
The discussion is for
folks who are struggling.
And I say, wrestle
with your struggle.
But at the same time, I choose
to live and be acknowledged
in my full humanity,
and nobody's
going to take that away.
I will fight for it--
claw-- try me.
That's all I have to say.
JANE SPAHR: So we
say, God is that which
happens between you and me.
And so we're
grateful that Google
would have us here, and let
us happen with you together.
And so we brought you a gift.
We brought you a rainbow
flag, and it's a large flag.
It's really around, how do we
break systems of oppression
that keep people from seeing
one another for who we are?
So we come with all that
the rainbow flag may be,
thanking you so much
for the opportunity
for Google to have us here.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
And I hope that everyone
would join me in applause.
[APPLAUSE]